Marvel's "Moon Knight" is here, with a
pair of personalities and a very cool suit.
The first episode is full of twists
and turns, but it's the ending that
reveals the most about Moon Knight
and his foes. Warning: spoilers ahead.
Steven Grant is a man tormented by a
situation that he doesn't fully understand,
and he tries to control his tendency to
wander around while he's unconscious with
a number of DIY tricks. It's clear that
this has been going on for a long time,
and "Moon Knight" Episode 1 is
when everything finally changes.
As the first episode nears its end,
Steven gets to peek behind the veil
when he discovers physical evidence
of another personality's existence,
tucked away in a hidey-hole in his apartment.
The cell phone he discovers is a particularly
important find because it introduces viewers
to multiple potentially important characters.
Shortly after discovering the old phone, Steven
gets a call. On the other end, an unfamiliar
woman named Layla has been trying to reach a
man named Marc for what appears to be weeks.
"Who do you think I am?"
"What do you mean 'who'?
What's wrong with you, Marc?"
Layla might very well turn out
to be the MCU version of Marc's
romantic interest in the comics, Marlene.
The other name in the missed calls list, DuChamp,
is also very interesting. DuChamp is
almost certainly "Frenchie" DuChamp,
Marc's old mercenary friend
and ally in the comics.
It remains to be seen whether his name is a simple
Easter egg or a tease of the character's on-screen
debut. Still, the fact that he exists in the MCU
implies that Marc and Frenchie's old mercenary
boss and Moon Knight's arguably greatest enemy,
Raoul Bushman also lurks somewhere in the world.
While Marc's formidable nemesis seems like
the kind of character the MCU might want to
save for "Moon Knight" Season 2 or even
a movie, fans will no doubt welcome this
low-key confirmation that Bushman might make
an appearance at some point down the line.
In the comics, Moon Knight's various
personalities often converse with each other,
and Khonshu is fond of making physical
appearances in all his bird skull-headed glory.
It's a pretty wild concept for a live-action show,
and indeed, "Moon Knight" episode 1 makes it clear
that the series intends to keep such interactions
at a relatively muted "voices in his head" level.
During a mid-episode chase scene,
F. Murray Abraham's Khonshu establishes himself
as a pestering presence that mostly uses his
booming voice to express exasperation
over Steven's lack of mercenary prowess.
"Ugh. The idiot's in control."
While the discovery of Marc's phone
finally clues Steven into the fact
that he shares his body with another identity,
it also spirals his life further into disarray.
His existence is suddenly all about Marc talking
to him through mirrors and Khonshu manifesting in
front of him in dramatic, horror movie fashion.
Though these experiences are obviously no fun for
Steven, the mirror dialog is an effective visual
technique that translates the identities' comic
book conversations to the live-action medium.
Meanwhile, Khonshu's ominous, stalking hallway
appearance is at complete odds with the almost
flippant way the character's disembodied voice
converses with Steven earlier in the episode.
This gives the viewer a glimpse of the
character's unpredictable, otherworldly
nature, as well as the moon god's tendency to
ignore the mental well-being of its avatar.
It becomes clear very quickly that Moon
Knight's primary nemesis, Arthur Harrow,
is more than a small-time cult leader with a
penchant for filling his shoes with ground glass.
Not only does the villain have the powers
of Ammit, an Egyptian goddess of justice,
but the cult he leads has also
infiltrated all levels of society.
This is revealed when Harrow confronts
Steven in the British Museum.
"You really do work here. I'd
assumed that Steven Grant was
an alias. Imagine my surprise to find you here."
Yet, the security guard, whom Steven knows and
who's clearly been at the museum for a while,
is a full member of Team Ammit. This fact is
confirmed when the guard reveals a scale tattoo
on his arm, similar to the one Harrow possesses.
It means that the guard has been at the museum
for reasons that have nothing to do with Steven,
which in turn implies one of two things. Either
Harrow placed the guard there for an entirely
unrelated purpose, or his cult is simply so
formidable that he has followers everywhere. Considering the museum's vast Egyptology
department with a vast collection of Ammit-themed
artifacts, the placement of the guard doesn't
seem accidental. And when Harrow proceeds to
outright state that his plans for the world
will cause millions of deaths, it becomes
clear that he's a global threat. While it
remains to be seen just how widespread the Cult
of Ammit is, this version of Arthur Harrow is
definitely a far more powerful and dangerous
man than the mad doctor from the comics.
As Harrow's summoned jackal creature corners
Steven in the museum bathroom and starts punching
its way through the heavy doors, it's clear that
the beast's strength matches its supernatural
creepiness. Fortunately, a panicked mirror
conversation between Steven and Marc convinces the
timid Brit to yield control of their shared body
just as the creature bursts through the doors.
"Steven. Steven, I can save us. But I
can't have you fighting me this time."
What follows is yet another scene straight out
of a horror movie, at least for the jackal.
Moon Knight completely and utterly
overwhelms and destroys the beast,
ignoring its feeble attempts to defend itself
and taking it down with a few brutal attacks.
This short scene ends the
episode with a punch, literally.
And while it gives viewers the first good
look at the awesome Moon Knight costume,
it also offers a sample of something even
more interesting, the character's powers.
Moon Knight's strength is all over the
place in the comics, to put it mildly.
Sometimes, he's just a well-trained guy
with some gadgets and kevlar. Other times,
he commands a vast array of superpowers that allow
him to take down the Avengers all by himself.
As such, it's interesting to see where on
this sliding scale the MCU character lands.
Based on the fact that he effortlessly
defeats the superpowered jackal creature,
it's clear that he's no weakling. There's no
telling what he can do when he unleashes his
weapons and really lets loose, but we have
a sneaking suspicion that future episodes
of "Moon Knight" will shed plenty
of light on his true power level.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about "Moon Knight"
are coming soon. Subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a single one.